people think it's crazy that I've eaten
200 grams of protein for almost 20
straight years every single day and I do
that because it's way easier for me to
live my life and of all the people that
I've seen who've been in insane shape
for extended periods of time they never
follow crash diets they never follow
anything crazy they follow a few rules
that works well for them for me I know I
have to have my 200 grams of protein
just to maintain the muscle mass that I
have and then in order to get my
calories in I just backfill whatever I
feel like to get the calories and so
whether that's cookies whether it's pies
whether it's cupcakes or a big bowl of
pasta and rice it doesn't really matter
of my shake I'll have a couple steaks
and then I'm good to go